Speaker 1: Okay, let's go next to Alan
from Miami, Florida. Alan, welcome.
Alan, you were on the air, but it looks
like you have the wrong microphone
selected. Welcome to the program. You can
speak if you can get configured correctly.
And the last chance for Allen from Miami,
Florida, who is in tech? Hell, as we might
call it. Welcome, Alan.
Speaker 3: Hello.
Speaker 1: Now I can hear you.
Speaker 3: How are you, David? I'm doing
well. Very good. So I had a question about Eve's.
I find it very interesting. I know you've talked
about them in the past on several occasions, so.
Now, as you probably know, the biggest issue with
Eve's from all from a cost standpoint is the the
most expensive part, right. Which is the battery.
And more specifically, the materials is sourced
and used to manufacture these batteries. Yes.
And if you look at the trajectory of the prices of
vehicles, their prices, they have been going down.
But the price of these of these batteries
are still big impediment, right?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 3: So what do you think
maybe the government can do? What kind of role do
you think their positive role and do you think the
government can play in trying to resolve this
issue or helping to resolve this issue? And the
reason I ask is because, you know, a lot of people
in the EV space will say that the the biggest
impediment is for the middle class or let's say,
just regular folk being able to afford an EV.
Is this issue basically is the cost of the
materials to manufacture the batteries?
Speaker 1: So there's a couple different
things here. First of all, in terms of
what the government can do, that's not the most
interesting question to me, because the government
can do what it's done in other industries that it
wants to support rebates, subsidies, preferential
tax treatment. The government has its tools that
it can use, and I'm fine with the government doing
that. I think the problem you're pointing out
is going to resolve itself with more electric
vehicle demand and as as adoption increases.
I mean, listen, it's like when you look at
computer processors, right? And you look at I
remember when we got from RadioShack, this 100
megahertz Pentium computer and it was like 20
$500 in whatever year that was, which is like a
lot more money now. You know, it's more like five
or six grand now. And now you get, you know, multi
gigahertz processors for way less by some of the
same laws that govern the reduced price of hard
drive storage and the reduced cost of processing
power. I think you're going to see absolutely the
same thing with with electric vehicle batteries.
The other thing is communicating to people
that because electric vehicles are so much more
efficient than internal combustion engines on a
per mile basis, it's also possible that while the
upfront cost of an electric vehicle can be higher
ah, although those costs are also coming down
the long term costs because the electricity is
cheaper than the gas and the efficiency is higher,
so your cost per mile is lower, the total cost of
ownership is going to be less. So I think it's
a matter of we've got to communicate that that's
already the case. The prices will continue to
come down. Battery recycling and reuse is going
to be developed. All of these things are these are
really engineering problems that are that are like
what we saw in computing and in other spaces.
It's all going to get resolved, is my view.
Speaker 3: Okay. I see what it seems to
me that that as far as you mentioned,
recycling, that's a huge thing that many
companies are trying to push is to try to get
these batteries to kind of get back into the the
life cycle because they still have valuable use.
But it seems and it could be wrong here, maybe
you can correct me on this, but it seems like I
don't know if the government or federal government
has any kind of program to recycle or incentivize
recycling of these things because.
Speaker 1: That I don't know.
They may. They may or they may not.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So that that could be an
area maybe that that that sort of the government
can, can can address. Because so far right now,
it seems like it's just startups that are coming
out of nowhere that are trying to resolve that
issue and the government isn't doing much.
Speaker 1: I would like the government to
more incentivizing this technology development,
but it's happening now and it's all happening.
Speaker 3: Thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you for the call. Appreciate
it. Alan from Miami, Florida. Quite a scene down
there that I can tell you for sure. Let's go. Oh,
just a reminder for everybody waiting in discord
to chat with me. If your nickname is anything
other than a name and a location, whether it's
nicknames or single words or whatever the case may
be, jokes you're not going to get called on, which
is fine if you're just listening. But just so you
know why, you won't be getting called on. Let's go
next to most Jeff from Toronto, Canada. Welcome.
Speaker 2: David Gallo. Hello. So I was
wondering, I don't know how how invested
you are in Canadian politics, but I was wondering
if I could get your opinion on how well you think
Justin Trudeau has been doing over the last while
and and your opinion about the they are the new
Conservative Party leader Conservative Party
leader pair party who just won the who just
won the race for Conservative Party leader.
Speaker 1: You know, I think it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to comment, not because I think
it's inappropriate to comment on foreign leaders,
but because there are just so many people who
follow it much more closely than I do, that I
couldn't possibly give you a very informed take.
I will say I recently, when I was in Montreal,
met with and chatted with MP Anthony House
father, who likes what Trudeau is doing,
but they're in the same party, right? So he
may have a dog in that fight, so to speak.
But no, I don't. I don't I don't think I'm
informed enough to really be saying, hey,
listen to my opinion about Canadian politics.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well, the lamps will always
vote for the people in their
party no matter what. Pretty
much. That's pretty much how it works there.
Speaker 1: Well, tell me, I mean, how do you
think things are day to day in Toronto?
Speaker 2: Well, yeah. I mean,
yeah. Reward you think with the cost of living
being in a pretty terrible place right now.
The government's working on getting dental care in
place. Which which is interesting. The question,
I guess, is the question are under
a you would think is is if now's the
right time to start implementing
like these, these are high cost
programs at this point where everyone is trying to
like save money, produce inflation. You know, you.
Speaker 1: Said a dental care program.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. They want some
they want to start doing a federal program.
You get coverage from the government for for
dental care because up until now, it's it's
that's completely been private and only only
paid for by private insurance.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, again,
without commenting specifically about what's
going on in Canada, there are always people who
will say this is the wrong time to do anything
that involves spending money. But my view tends
to be when it comes to things like health
care, why would you wait? People the sooner
people get care, the better off we are.
Speaker 2: Even if that means risking the
like the money being like that
money being spent elsewhere. Well.
Speaker 1: You'd have to then say, well, what
else do you want to spend it on and compare.
Speaker 2: Oh I would say not spend.
Speaker 1: Not spend it at all.
Speaker 2: As of. As of this moment. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay. All right. Well,
I'd like to see the numbers on it, but again,
I'm not the best position to comment on that.
Speaker 2: Okay. All right.
Thank you for your time.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks, Moshe
from Toronto, great to hear from you.